.
THE CEO AND FOUNDER OF THE
CENTER FOR AMERICAN LIBERTY
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
TELL US WHAT THIS SUIT ALLEGES.
>> WELL, AS YOU MENTIONED,
TUCKER, TAYLOR LORENZ, WHO HAS
JUMPED AROUND FROM VARIOUS
PUBLICATIONS, NOW AT "THE
WASHINGTON POST," HAS MADE HER
CAREER OUT OF CLOUT-CHASING,
INCREASING THEIR STATURE BY
PICKING VICTIMS WHO HAPPEN TO BE
ON THE UPSWING IN THE PUBLIC EYE
AND ATTACKING THEM VICIOUSLY,
FIRST OF ALL, TRYING TO SIDE UP
TO THEM, MAKE FRIENDS WITH THEM,
AND ULTIMATELY GUTTING THEM LIKE
A FISH, USING THAT MATERIAL FOR
HER PIECES.
ALONG THE WAY, VIOLATING ALL
KINDS OF ETHICAL RULES IN
JOURNALISM.
IN THIS CASE, SHE FOCUSED ON A
CLIENT, RUNNING INFLUENCER
HOUSES AND MANAGING TALENT ON
TIKTOK, YOU KNOW, BELIEVE IT OR
NOT, IT'S A HUGE INDUSTRY WORTH
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS, AND OUR
CLIENT WAS ON THE UPSWING THERE.
GIVEN FIVE HOURS TO RESPOND TO
HER HIT PIECE QUESTIONS IN
WRITING, WHICH IS HER MO, THE MO
OF OTHER DISHONESTLY
JOURNALISTS, SHE WAS PROVIDED
WITH INFORMATION DEBUNKING MANY
OF THE LIES SHE PUBLISHED IN HER
STORY, AND HAVING WRITTEN
INFORMATION IN HAND, DEBUNKING
THESE LIES, SHE WENT AHEAD AND
PUBLISHED ANYWAY, AND FOLLOWED
IT UP WITH POSTS ON SOCIAL
MEDIA, LYING ABOUT OUR CLIENT'
BUSINESS PRACTICES, SPECIFIC
CUBBING, THE WAY THESE HOUSES
WERE SET UP AND SAFETY AND
SECURITY AROUND THEM, CALLING
OUR CLIENT A BAD ACTOR ON SOCIAL
MEDIA, AND BASICALLY DESTROYING
OUR CLIENT'S CAREER AND CAUSING
HER DAMAGE IN THE TUNE OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
NOW, THIS ISN'T THE FIRST TIME
TAYLOR LORENZ HAS TRIED TO DO
THIS.
SHE BEEFED WITH HER CO-WORKERS
AT "THE NEW YORK TIMES," LAST
WEEK AT "THE WASHINGTON POST,"
AND OTHER JOURNALISTS.
THIS LADY IS A ONE-WOMAN
WRECKING CREW.
I'M HOPING THIS WE WILL BE THE
ONES TO HOLD HER ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Tucker: SHE'S A BULLY WHO
NEEDS